[Music]
[Applause]
luna
the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto
it's the perfect place to start
welcome back to my show as always it is
powered by icon plus capital
so quick news announcement for you
before we jump in because today's one
is different i feel like they're all
different so this is going to be fun
so icons d by balance dao launched last
month with over 180 million dollars in
total
locked in value um more d5 products are
coming in may
fiat on and off ramps bridge and open
money market on finance so some
always always more updates coming from
icon there
now this is sponsored by blockbuy so
gonna give them a quick shout out you
can get up to 250
when you sign up um which is pretty cool
and you can get up to 8.6
interest on your usdc that's also pretty
great given everything's kind of like
negative interest at the moment
particularly across europe so that's
really
good news there um this is also live on
youtube so if you're watching on youtube
make sure you hit the follow
turn hit the subscribe button hit the
like button so you never miss um
any of my guests so today's guest is
marin
altman the beautiful woman using the
stars to trade the crypto markets this
is pretty insane
marin how are you i'm doing very well
how are you doing today
i'm good i'm good so where are you at
the moment it looks stunning
i'm on my hotel balcony in dubai and if
everything could be shown i am right in
front of the marina
the sun is setting it's beautiful so
here visiting probably for the final
time before it gets too hot before i
apply for a residence
so quick quick trip here that's amazing
where are you from initially
i am from new york born and raised in
texas but live in new york
and um that's where i might be splitting
my time up with here in dubai in the
future
just kind of avoiding those those
covered restrictions texas
dubai i love it i love it
yeah but i've seen a lot of your work um
it kind of popped up in the end of 2020
the beginning of 2021 um so
i have so many questions for you because
it's so different from anything that
i've seen before
you know people are always looking at
the fundamentals people are always
looking
at technical analysis and obviously i'm
sure you take those things into account
as well but
you look at astrology so you could
really explain it better than i can can
you ex how would you define what you do
yeah i look at planetary cycles and the
positions of planetary bodies at certain
moments
in correlation with events on earth or
cycles of events in history on earth
so some astrologers use that in a more
psychological context to look at how
certain patterns correlate with certain
psychological
or life events for individuals
in my adolescence i began to realize
that i had a passion
for astrology in a more worldly context
and then as i entered my 20s
found finance i found that the specific
worldly context i liked to look at those
correlations within were financial
markets
okay so break all of that down because i
have to be honest i really don't
understand like
i just don't maybe it's because i'm not
as um i
don't know the word i don't use creative
but because it's not the word but i just
don't understand like i see your videos
and i don't get it
so it's the astrology part go on how you
explain
yeah so at any given moment the planets
are all positioned
in different ways around the earth in
certain angles
and certain combinations and planets
themselves
represent certain things and we have
discovered that
through millennia of writing it down
when certain alignments
and then certain events happen so
there's a lot of built up data
to have theses around this planet and
aspect to this planet
indicates this kind of an event so with
that
we can look at the moment that someone
or something was born
whether that's a person or whether that
is a company
or that is a token and see how the
current sky
is in alignment with it um kind of like
you might think of weather forecasting
but then how that applies to the
geography of a given place
so that if you're looking that there's
if if you see there's going to be rain
coming somewhere
you'll still take that in context with
what the initial climate is whether it's
rains a lot
whether rain is not very common to
put together what's happening versus the
context for where it's happening
and then form um form an inference so
i'm seeing alignments that represent
mostly either favorable or unfavorable
alignments um favorable being indicative
of a price
increase or good news for like a project
or a token
and then unfavorable being something
detrimental or something that looks
more like you know a bearish indicator
for the market
so it's very very similar to technical
analysis where we're using patterns to
predict the future because it's all
cyclical
um it just happens that the chart is
circular and
not candlestick so yeah so
can you give me an example of what would
be a good thing and what would be a bad
thing i know that could be quite broad
but just so i can really wrap my head
around what you look for
sure so the favorable planets are
generally jupiter and venus
they indicate i just like to say cute
generally jupiter
yeah so yeah so in middle of may around
may 16th
jupiter in the sky will be crossing over
the location
that venus was at when bitcoin's genesis
block
was released so okay jupiter's crossing
the exact location
of where venus is in bitcoin's chart so
like jupiter plus venus
double cute essentially so trying
to simplify it down that way
astrology is a hell of a lot of math
that i don't do myself i get
calculations to do and then i just see
it and i'm like okay
jupiter crossing venus that's favorable
something happening around the same time
is that
um the two planets that indicate
unfavorable things
or bearishness are mars and saturn
and um mars will be opposing pluto
where it was in bitcoin's chart at its
time of the genesis block
which is mars in a direct opposition
to another planet pluto which can be
more unfavorable
looks more bearish so we're seeing kind
of um
a game of combination and then what is
the last results because often there's
going to be multiple things going on
and you have to see which are more
powerful or what you're outweighing the
the other side so it might sound
ridiculous
um because obviously you do this so you
obviously nothing sounds ridiculous
okay good that's scary okay so how
effective
is it so like how much um
what kind of results have you had by
following this um
system when it comes to trading and
because you trade right
yeah i do i do i'm definitely in profit
because of this
um preemptively i i
am more geared towards i mean me myself
being a more like
skeptical or critical person i can spot
unfavorables and like oh that looks bad
like it's going to go down
so i'm going to be like i want to have
usdt on hand
to buy in and then there's a really
striking correlation
with full moons being local bottoms and
new moons being local tops there was a
chart right recently
full moons hormones being local bottoms
of it yeah whether it's an uptrend or a
downtrend like just local bottoms as it
ebbs and flows
and new moons being local tops so for
example
if i am um more short-term trading all
coins like swing trading
i will try to buy in around the full
moon for things that i think
have a fundamental and a technical
narrative to back it so like i use all
three where
every time it's around a full moon i'm
thinking what positions do i want to add
to
what narratives are bringing the space
right now i'm really bullish on exchange
tokens
and um also like nft projects so i'll
add positions to those
around the new moon i'll then look and
see what looks like there might be
bullish divergence a narrative dying out
to where i think it looks a bit
overvalued and i'll take profit
so i use it and i'm
in profit i am not perfect there are
times when i
am like that was there are times where i
look back i'm like oh my god that was a
like
why didn't you see that so i'm
definitely not uh
infallible like i it's human error but
it is
really key for narrowing down and not
being overwhelmed with
the ta or fundamental analysis that can
seem like there are so many different
options of where to go
i can narrow it down with astrology yeah
and astrology is one of those things um
like
so many things in life whether it's like
um
uh bear with me you know like hypnosis
or um
or alternative medicine you know all
these sorts of alternative things
which people laugh at um and they don't
believe in right so yes and now
now you're bringing this into something
which is let's just call it a man's
world because because it is and this is
something that like yeah
men totally you know oppose like women
are more interested in astrology women
are more interested in alternative
medicine
women are more interested in in all the
like
fluffy stuff let's just call it so so
what kind of
backlash have you had because you know
you're really putting this in like
you're bringing astrology into maths and
and
science and stuff like that yeah so
really yeah this came really organically
in the way that like
2020 started i was like i'm graduating
from university i don't know jack
about finance
i am practical but i wasn't taught
anything i'm a philosophy student like i
didn't know
anything about anything i had a debit
card january 2020 i
i open up rich dad poor dad i'm like
no wonder in my own astrology there's a
huge emphasis on finance that i refuse
to acknowledge for all of my life
because i was like i'm going to be an
actor like
why is there money like what what
interest do you have in being an
accountant um now i see no it's because
you're interested in finance itself but
um i started getting really into
investing and diving into crypto
at the march 2020 crash and it just
became like my obsession
literally i was like this is when
history is made um so you better
like really ape into this and it was
such an honest
interest in crypto and then using
astrology because that's what i know how
to use
to chart trends that as it emerged and i
started posting about it on tik tok as i
was growing for political videos as well
i didn't even think about like i didn't
i didn't know that there were like
astrologers that were already doing this
that were doing crypto and astrology now
i'm aware of like there are a number of
financial structures who do do crypto
but i was just kind of like this is fun
for me
and then during the fall um accounts
like tick tock investors
and some other ones started posting them
and
i'm a pretty i like to say like i just
don't take
too much overly seriously like
i don't know like the mimification of me
like calling me thinking i'm crazy i'm
like bring it i don't really care
so i'd say the backlash i find it mostly
even if they might mean it maliciously i
don't i don't know i don't take it
maliciously
um i think it's funny i'm like i'm
shattering their worldview and that's
fine
this is welcome uh so it definitely had
a lot of backlash either uh favorably or
unfavorably i guess
like there's been some weird ones like
ben shapiro retweeted me and that was
it was a video about the election that
involved financial markets really going
through trouble in early 2021
and um it was just a weird thing where
she
he was like this is better than like
what did he say the like
some he mentioned some financial uh
analyst
group and then and 538 yeah and it was a
weird moment because i remember i'm just
eating breakfast at the same table that
i've been at my entire
you know 20 early 20s um and
now this is happening so i'd say the
backlash is mostly shock oriented
even if they might need a malicious
sleep i don't take that much seriously
and i'm like it's all in good fun so
feel free keep my name in your mouth
like go for it i'm cool for chillin
so yeah yeah i think that's such a great
mentality um
i think the thing with this space is
that um everybody is very set in their
ways
and it's i've noticed that people don't
necessarily like mass adoption
um because it kind of feels like it's
and it's a club and it's something that
we
have and you know i guess and i can
understand that and i really can because
like
having been in this space for a few
years now i do sort of feel like you
know when i've been telling my friends
by bitcoin and then they don't
and then now everybody's asking i'm sort
of just like go away you know so
i can understand um but you said that
you
studied philosophy and you only recently
got into finance that's amazing so i
want to hear more about that so the
crash in march
2020 that's what it was how did you
learn about crypto then because that was
literally a year ago yeah so
january 2020 is when i was like yeah you
don't know anything like literally you
have a debit card and you don't you
don't even like i'm
i wasn't bad with money necessarily i'm
a responsible person it's just not
something they teach you and
i was very heavy into like not even in
philosophy i was not into philosophy of
science or logic
i openly nearly failed logic because it
was so difficult for me to quantify
basic things like
the coding classes i took which were
very basic were
something that i could tell was
basically was just not the way that i
think um and so i geared more towards
ethics and metaphysics and like
philosophy of language and things like
that
um and once i started preparing to
graduate
um kovitz started kind of creeping in
and i realized like i just had a lot
more time on my hands
to not have to commute to class every
day like in new york and
that led to one joining tick-tock and
two being able to read more like for
pleasure
and i really like non-fiction so i
bought rich dad poor dad
i bought the little common sense book of
investing which both of them convinced
me
by assets not liabilities good tip um
and then the little common sense book of
investing
taught me to buy low-cost index funds
and i thought i had solved the world i
was like
i'm gonna buy low-cost index funds i'm
gonna beat the market told all my
friends i'm like
buy low-cost index funds lo and behold i
open an ira
and uh accidentally put the entire year
maximum into tesla which worked out very
well
but was not as i intended i meant to buy
an index fund messed it up
that was actually the catalyst for how
can this be so difficult for me to buy
something
be delayed it'd be difficult for me to
set up these accounts accidentally make
six iras barely qualify basically for
these bank accounts
because i don't know i'm like not i was
just graduating university i was like
why is it so difficult for me to just
open a bank account like this is
ethically ridiculous like the middlemen
component of this is just insane i
i don't know if something's inefficient
and intolerable like i don't i don't
stand by i'm going to be like why
that philosophical background of like
interrogating things and finding a
uh like i'm utilitarian i like to
maximize efficiency and pleasure and
minimize harm and ridiculousness and so
when things are out of balance with that
my mind is like when is the equation
wrong and the financial system it was
like
business this is absurd and from there
i found crypto pretty easily because
philosophy student
plus interest in finance was like
bitcoin
likes kind of entry level uh
libertarian financial kind of meetings
was pretty pretty
immediate i did not buy into crypto
immediately because i was so interested
in learning more about it
i then bought into it later in the
summer and all i did
that entire year because i don't spend
that much or need that much to live on
was put everything i could into bitcoin
everything everything and
uh from that that then allowed me to
have a good time i just closed yeah
yeah yeah um and
from there it gave me like i like to
consider
money just a form of pure energy of
transaction and the way that we exchange
exchange energy and building that up
throughout the year
allowed me to then have more more of a
canvas to play with ethereum and
altcoins and things like that
so um my crypto journey came from being
like i need to grow up
i should learn about finance uh this is
highly ridiculous and crypto seems to be
the next logical step in addressing that
ridiculousness
and i think what's interesting is you
said that it was kind of the mixture of
philosophy and bitcoin which kind of
made sense
so okay so what kind of philosophy
because for me
i might i was in politics first like i'm
in love with politics i'm a libertarian
um
and so that's why the connection was
just like
duh obviously so when you say philosophy
do you mean political philosophy
or do you mean i i guess philosophy kind
of extends to that
um but what kind of philosophy really
yeah the philosophy that i specialized
in war looked
like i was really big into ethics and in
particular i got really deep into
utilitarianism because i
have a pretty myopic mind and so i like
weighing out the utility
to the point of driving myself crazy of
like what is the simplest path to this
what will maximize return to the point
where sometimes i'm so focused on
maximizing return i get no return
which happens in my financial decisions
as well i can be
doing so much research on all coins and
what kind of allocation i want in a
company to where the opportunity passes
and
it's already gone up or something so
there's pluses and minuses to being an
over analyst but
the philosophy that i think led me into
yeah similarly libertarian leanings was
looking into actually i did a class on
political philosophy and ethics and we
read a lot of john stewart mill
um like on liberty and reading that and
there were some points that i highly
agreed with which was kind of the um
ways that society molds things into
usually a healthier ecosystem but can
remove the innovation that comes with
non-conformism
um and things like that where i just
started to think on a larger worldview
of the systems that we were creating and
how some of them are just
cultural inertia rather than
linear progress i'm really into i mean i
guess like
every early 20s girl i'm really into
nietzsche and on the genealogy of morals
i that really spoke to me early in my
college career because
it um very clearly laid out how we are
not on a linear path to improvement
maybe we are like the market kind of
eventually going up but there's a lot of
ups and downs in different areas of the
world
and i felt like the financial system was
a great example of going very very far
in a certain direction with
trying to help out by interfering a lot
in the world when perhaps the
best solution is occam's razor and like
get everything out and let the
free market world kind of correct itself
and seeing 2020 be the opposite of that
where our stock market is on stilts
um i think that there's so much
artificiality that it brings in ethical
considerations
so my philosophy of wanting the simplest
path because that brings in the least
i guess uh casualties that are just
extraneous in the world
and the utilitarian path of just like
just just cut to the
just the simplest thing which does not
seem to be this extreme manipulation
um led me very very quickly into crypto
and i think that energetic alignment is
why i've been extremely lucky with the
people and
the opportunities that i've been able to
meet up with in this space
and you mentioned john you mentioned
john stuart mill so i did a class on
ethics um
when i was at university and um
philosophy and all that stuff and he's
the guy that speaks about um
freedom of speech right he's the one
that says if um
if we all just tell the truth eventually
sorry if we allow freedom of speech the
truth will eventually rise to the top
so that's like something which really
kind of shaped my political leanings
and therefore bitcoin and everything
like that like i think what's really
interesting
is all the tribalism in the space um i
think i just saw today
um that um i can't remember how to
pronounce his last name but chama
so he's a bitcoin og like he bought
bitcoin right in his words when everyone
else was still
still in their mom's basement right
right um
but he dabbles in other things and is
interested in other coins
supposedly coins so he's been
de-platformed which i thought was really
interesting
um because john stuart mills is the guy
that i kind of
really connected with when he said yeah
freedom of speech
and then the truth will rise to the top
um i wonder if you had any thoughts on
any of the tribalism
yeah well for one that's kind of sad
because i can definitely disagree with
chemoth on some things mostly because i
come from a point of
for better for worse a beginner's mind
in the grand scheme of things where i
might
have less tainting but also a bit of
naivete so like some of the things he
says i'm like
but then i don't know but i i appreciate
jamal for the most part
um so i'm sad to see that he will not be
at the conference that i actually will
be going to the lectures for because i'm
a nerd like i actually want to see these
things so i was excited to see him but
alas i think that the tribalism and i've
seen other people
speak about this is because of the
ethical or the philosophical
conviction that nearly everyone gets
into the space with whether that is a
conviction
that we should accumulate profit because
that you know is something that has been
taken away from a lot of people that
might not have access to generational
wealth which i think
is an ethical motive you know i don't
see profit or money as
bad or negative it's simply energy and i
think there's some people who
more like me it was the efficiency or
the wrongdoing of the gatekeeping and
the
euphemisms that make finance seem like
this old guys club and it's really just
the discussion of energy and you can put
whatever word you want on it but
it's not that difficult like
it's not as difficult as these words
make it seem um yes that
got me into the space with an awareness
of
kind of the um the emotions that come in
with it and i think that
it's a lot of people's replacement for
myth or for
story or narrative in their life to feel
like they're working directly with a
medium of value
and that their path to working with that
value is justified and
i remember i don't think i realized the
gravity of what i was saying because i
can agree wholeheartedly that bitcoin is
the best store of value as a digital
gold out of any coin philosophically
completely agree i think it will get to
a point where we all want to be holding
a certain amount of bitcoin for you know
like this is my safety net
i used to call myself a reformed bitcoin
maxi because i like to leverage all
coins that will return much higher to
then have a bigger safety net of bitcoin
that does not fly because i'm not
hodling and i'm not i don't know like
sleeping with
a ledger under my pillow of just like
the bitcoin that i bought in like
1995 2012 13. i don't know but like
um i think that part of the tribalism is
a
you know replacement for a myth or
religion or
community in a space that often comes
out of feeling like you
take issue with the communities that
people are ascribing to whether that is
left right
like members of this whatever in the
world it's a lot of
um factions that arise out of meaning
well and i think that if you were
like i used to say ironically a big a
reformed bitcoin maxi i didn't fully
mean that you know i
i don't have huddle in my name um and my
twitter handle
but i think that anyone who
wholeheartedly is a
maximalist i think it's a little
narrow-minded because there's always
a caveat and um i
think it is in good fun i i you know i
invite all the different factions and
groups and i don't take it too seriously
i'm just kind of like you know
my i guess my fact is just like
maximizing the simplest path to making
the best of the space
um and like i'm leverage different coins
for that
yeah i think you have the correct
mindset you can't take any of this too
seriously you absolutely cannot
um if you take it too seriously you're
just going to be miserable um
and i'm totally with you like i i also
agree i think bitcoin is digital gold
it's the best store of value we've ever
seen like michael saylor says it's
you know the best savings technology
there is it's my safety net
it's the love of my life it's the thing
which is basically you know
gonna be there if all else fails um
but you know if you can make some quick
gains i don't see why not
you know you can trade some old coins to
buy more bitcoin i don't get why it's
that deep and why it's that emotional
but i definitely agree with you um
when you say you know yeah it's not but
i definitely agree with you when you say
that
um you know people need that kind of
like community and i do think that
that's where
where it comes from because we see
tribalism you know
across the board whether it's in whether
it's religion
um gender um oh have i still got you
yeah you're going to like the shutter
yeah mine does that as well
i'm good yeah i'm going to you can keep
going i'm here i'm going to delete the
um the video that is taking up space
because now that i'm in dubai
i uh don't have oh go for it no worries
so yeah so whether it whether it's you
know tribalism in um
in sports whether it's tribalism you
know with gender
politics whatever it is i feel like
people always need
people always need some form of
community to belong to and i do think
that's what it comes down to
um but you made a video which i thought
was really cool it totally blew up so
congrats
um the video was about bitcoin scarcity
and
how um okay how do i put this because i
want to try
try try articulate this basically you
you're looking at yourself as a woman
going through her 20s and
you were saying as i get older i have
less time left
that makes me more valuable that makes
my time more valuable
just like bitcoin i thought that was
really cool so can you tell me more
about this how did you
um come to that train of thought yeah
in the way that i conceptualize a lot of
the reasons why i'm interested in crypto
it generally does go back to like
philosophy and
even if i'm quote in it for the tech
it's because like it's tech that i think
is going to philosophically change the
world
um yeah and so with that
when i think of bitcoin it was just
really life-changing to be like
you can hold something for money that is
of value um and isn't just like
discovering the difference between the
frivolousness or meaninglessness of fiat
currency versus something that
is even it's though it's intangible it's
meaningful um
spoke to me and with bitcoin increasing
in value the less that it is available
i started thinking of like how a lot of
my worries for the future
come with a lot of my career was
leveraged on sure
providing like valuable insightful
things but no one
no one would have spotted me in the
first place if i wasn't you know black
and red haired
looked the way i did the kinds of things
that come with the awareness of being
like a young woman
and knowing that biologically like i'm
in like
the peak of being able to use this and
i'm not afraid to speak about it or be
like that's kind of a weird concept to
think of like looking back i mean like
that was
the height of when i was most
captivating physically online
what would be a way of knowing that i
would be worth
taking up space and value when it's not
the immediate you know
gut impulse to watch them because of
what they look like and if bitcoin gets
more valuable the less that it exists in
the world
because what remains is valuable so
therefore less of it
is exponentially more valuable then why
isn't
me who i would consider valuable in what
i provide also being thought of as more
valuable the less of me that remains
and i don't think that's morbid um i
feel really comfortable discussing death
and i guess the fear or acknowledgement
of the downside of aging
and i really find especially women who
just like hold their openness with aging
like i
i like to see like almost like beautiful
aging on people because i i think it
speaks to this
um but if bitcoin can be valuable as
there's less of it remaining then maybe
it's not so bad for me to get old and
wrinkly and
uh just be a brain and not so much a
body anymore maybe it
means it's more valuable in the long run
yeah i i totally
um i i totally understood your train of
thought when you posted that
and i was like that's that's really
funny that um like somebody i've never
spoken to
is is kind of like thinking like that
and i totally understood it
um what was the kind of reaction you had
because i know obviously it was
it blew up but like what kind of
response did you get
funny enough i posted it on tick tock
and
didn't blow up at all um i yeah because
on tick tock what blows up is the very
like click bait 15 second joke videos
and there are times when authentically
i'm in a good mood i want to post that
and they're also most of the time when i
know that i don't consume
any content like that i consume very
little tick tock maybe one to two videos
when i open the app to post
but i don't sit there scrolling and when
i do look at something it's usually a
one minute
crypto or philosophy or personal finance
or real estate related video
so i don't sit there and watch any of
the trends so
when that video didn't really blow up in
tiktok i wasn't surprised because
um definitely now thinking in terms of
value not just
views when i posted it on twitter and it
started to blow up and i gained
some followers that i really respect in
the space like some thinkers i know
found me through that it was kind of
interesting to see that
people could resonate because i even
though i have had quite a few
incredible viral opportunities that is
just the surface
of the amount of like hundreds of
thousands of pieces of content that
don't get seen
that are more valuable than that that
usually gets seen so
sure there were some weird things where
people didn't bother to watch the video
and most of the it doesn't bother me
when people leave quote physical hate
like i couldn't care less i grew up
acting this is a biological space suit i
don't care say what you want to try to
make a funny point
some people were like this is a top
signal and like that was old in october
like i been here like thank you
no someone else thought of that joke
um and then some of them were just kind
of like
this is weird that bitcoin maxies think
this and i'm like the bitcoin maxies
don't blame me
yeah yeah so most every single criticism
was a misunderstanding or a projection
of trying to make a joke and be witty
exactly exactly whereas 90 of it was
like wow and i'm like oh like people
appreciate it like i to this day
anytime i get it's inhuman to be able to
consider the amount of people that might
appreciate what i'm doing so anytime i
can see and connect with that it's like
oh thank you even if i like
like every single time like when people
see me and i'm checking my comments i'm
like oh like i'm visually
like in like reacting so it was that's
why i
pinned it and i don't usually have a pin
tweet because i'm like there's
there's no point um because of how fast
the space moves but
that spoke to me and i did it i did it
in dubai a month ago
in the same hotel like two it was this
floor like two
um balconies down at night no makeup the
night before my flight at like 2 a.m
just filmed it like it worked yeah
yeah i think you know that's the best
kind of content where
it just comes from the heart it's
totally random yeah
um and yeah it just comes from the heart
and
i i i totally get it i think it was i
think it was really really interesting
thank you um so in terms of your
personal life and your career goals
where do you see yourself i know you
said you're obviously moving to
dubai um but outside of that like woody
where do you see yourself what are you
doing for work what are the goals
yeah so yeah the current priority is
uh because of where i see the world
heading and there's actually a good
quote i believe it's jim rogers who said
something along the lines of
1800 you moved to london 1900 you moved
to new york
2000's you moved to asia and the same
energy that had me
moved to new york from texas because i
felt like that go-getter energy of
wanting to change the world is the same
exact energy that can see that
i want to keep a place in new york i
don't want to depend or live there
full-time
and places in asia like dubai or
singapore
where the priority is on maximizing
freedoms
and using the government in a way that
keeps sanity instead of
impedes on businesses especially because
there's not a
demonization of success or wealth
because it's understood that that is
simply a lot of energy
and that can be either required poorly
or really authentically
um i can see where that's heading and so
i'm thinking
firstly that a career goal is to for one
set up you know
businesses and things outside of the
country um as i you know prepare to be
more
um be more in like the asian i see this
kind of an emerging intellectual
market for this kind of uh liberty based
work
i want to create things that
are not fighting against where history
is heading and i think history is
heading towards a.i
and decentralization and i love
astrology
and i know that i am passionate about
research and what i've done so far
however i think that the future will be
ai and that actually scared me a few
years ago there were pieces i made where
i thought it was like ethically wrong
and now i've really completely gone
around the corner where i'm like
if it scares me because it's new then i
want to join forces with it there's
several projects that i'm heavily
invested in because i'm like
that's going to scare people and piss
people off like i want to be on the
front lines for that
and can you tell me more about that what
kind of like what kind of ai
scared you and that yeah i had a change
of heart on i
i think that i was honestly um
surrounded by in a mind space
of really wanting like humanness
to not go out of style or be valued for
simply being human like
me value us and now i see it as
the benefit to humanity can come when
more and more is automated and
less and less can be done by humans that
what is done by humans
is more valuable because the value of
our work or the
the amount of energy it takes to do our
work will fill to the amount of space
that we are provided so if we live in a
huge house and we're alone
that might be more detrimental to your
day-to-day routine than living in a
adequately but more concise space if you
give yourself three weeks to write a
one-page paper
it's probably going to be extremely
taxing as opposed to three hours to
write that paper
um it's just gonna drag out so if
i if we can have less to fill as humans
that doesn't require
um if we can outsource extraneous
monotonous tasks or
tasks that can be better done by
automation it will allow us
to be forced to work within a system
that maximizes our potential and
astrology one-on-one consultations are
beautiful
and i think that scaling that is not as
sustainable as thinking i want to build
a platform
that can provide astrological
delineations and things
not just in a cookbook style but like
more intelligent where ai
i'm not um extremely literate on the
science of ai but i do understand that
you know there's intelligence
to it it's not you know uh it's not a
formula like
regular you know maybe yeah of course
yeah so i think that
if we can outsource that and we can
continue trying to build to maximize ai
which is just smarter and is going to
have
i get that in astrology there's a human
compassion component with the way that
you present something and also there's
error in that
you might get the calculation wrong you
might delineate it wrong
with ai i think that there's less room
for air and a lot of that so i would in
the future like to develop a system that
is decentralized so that it's not like
writers getting to put their favoritism
or bias into what the ai is saying but
i i know co-stars all is already doing
this to an extent and i did a video
where i railed on co-star and like
if i ever meet these people like i want
to i didn't really blow up i was a
nobody until
six months ago but i would honestly be
like you know i apologize i had a change
of heart keep doing you because it
scares people and it pisses people off
but i can see behind that in the future
it'll be this is what's done to further
businesses
um and i think decentralization is the
future because
as as we have more space to make
day-to-day decisions
the more complex decisions reveal
themselves as being
silly so like the fact that going
towards bank you have intermediaries
ach i just had to do to get my polish
passport that i'm getting through
dissent
is like five days to wire a couple
hundred euros like i was literally like
can i just send you ethereum they're
like what is ethereum i'm like
okay thank you um and i think that
decentralization is just a product of
efficiency
and people with efficiency there comes
more time and space to think and people
realize when there's unnecessary steps
so decentral i think like d5 projects
i want to build some of my own and i'm
very
aware that it's very real that there's a
possibility of talented people who
use me as a public figure to not create
the best project
have it maybe fall through and that's on
me so i'm extremely careful in not
wanting to be as naive as i am now
before launching but i think
anything that liberates people from like
i guess allows them to
be more sovereign with the way that
their manage their energy aka their
money
is so necessary so i'm very focused on
astrology within ai
and d5 in general in mostly like
i don't know there's a bunch of d5
projects that are like um
staking yield farming collateral is it
collateralization like cross
chain like whatever and i'm like i don't
i don't i you lost you lost me about the
third term
how can i just help the average person
in a way that leverages the geniuses
that are developers
and also makes the average person more
stable because no one should be
living paycheck to paycheck um i think
equal opportunity is important it's what
people decide to do with that and defile
out for that
yeah i think um so there's so much there
so i'll just click
a pick up of your last yeah so i i'm
also with you like i'm not super super
techy
i'm in a world where i'm trying to
essentially liaise that message
from the geniuses the techie people
to the average person who just wants to
find value right um
right so that's very much my my goal as
well and i think like
in terms of ethics i i look at the
traditional financial system and i just
think it's so
it's not just trash but it's actually a
scam that is set out to hurt the little
person
and so i you when i look at these
different d5 projects and like
you know the different kind of interests
that people can make and yield farming
and all this stuff and i'm just like wow
you know like this could be really
interesting
um right you said you said something
earlier and i can't
remember what it was but i really wanted
to pick you pick you up on it
um oh ai okay so on the ai point
i'm with you i definitely understand the
whole outsourcing and you know it can
it means that we can make our time more
valuable and purposeful
you know we understand that in business
anyway um
but but but i have this thing where i
feel
i'm concerned that if we really remove
the human
from the human experience it's going to
make things
dark and dull for example um so i went
out for
lunch back in summer in england when um
it was open but because of covin they
weren't serving you directly
and i think i went into this restaurant
i ate a full meal and i didn't speak to
one person that worked there
the entire time no waiter no like
and it just wasn't nice and i didn't
like it and then i
thought to myself okay well this is this
is where we're going with a.i
um and i didn't like it i much more
prefer to have the human
involved what do you think
i think that's definitely you could
argue a bug or a feature
depending on your preference in the
context because
i agree that now some of the things that
seem like they will be here to stay
um similar to how 911 enforce new
restrictions for travel and
uh gathering this has introduced things
like
especially in dubai where it's um the
cutting edge of a lot of the ways in
which this was dealt with and it got a
handle on things very quickly
like there's very rarely menus it's all
qr codes and something about that like
i like i'm like i'm like a paper person
like i like to grab i i don't know if
this is
like i smell my books and i like menus
and tangible things
heavy earth sign energy in my chart i
like to be grounded and like feel things
and
that feeling and also um the rise of
just
i don't even know like calling or
dealing with a problem online with
customer service and being completely
automated and then sometimes they're not
understanding you
does worry me in some ways that
when there's an issue sometimes the
creativity and the softness of humans
can fill in gaps
and misplaced parties
where if it's a system and there's a
part that doesn't fit you're just going
to be
kept out so that if there's a mishap
it's more likely to be more noticeable
so i think it's a case-by-case thing but
there are some things where
my motto throughout this has been like
if i'm really bullish on ai
it makes me motivated to live a life
that ai cannot replicate
and most things it can and then one that
it may be
like when i think of anything whether
it's being like witty
or provocative or saying things that um
seem cutting edge i think in a i might
do that better because i might
not have the emotional setback of like
that's going to piss people off it might
have a faster reaction time to doing
you know more productive statement or
with or whatever um so it's a
case-by-case thing of trying to maximize
my crew of
creativity and my individuality and um
not having an answer to whether it's
right or whether
it is better and personal preference in
some ways because
some things i don't want to deal with
the human about and some things and like
i miss menus and waiters and things like
that
yeah i miss menus i'm totally with you
um yeah
but i wonder do you have an opinion on
elon musk's um
simulation theory then given your
interest in ai do you think we're in a
simulation
kind of like the idea of free will you
can make the idea of a simulation
into whatever fits your comfort zone
with the kind of reality we're in
so if you literally think that we are in
the one-to-one equivalent of a computer
game with another species watching or
playing
i don't think that i think that you
could argue that this
is a playing ground for a larger
architecture of the universe i think
that astrology and the way that there's
correlations that repeat over time
hints at a larger intelligence than just
humans and that's not
woo it's similar to how aliens are
likely and we still have little proof
it's likely just given the way in which
reality is structured but we have little
causal proof of this and i
think that the simulation theory um
if you want to argue that we're in a
simulation um i would
want you to explain the implications of
what that causally means like are we
agents of our own will
are we playing for entertainment for
someone
um because you could argue that life is
a simulation because we all have our own
reality
or you could argue that it's a
simulation because like me you think
more in terms of there must be something
greater than this
not in a magical way but just honestly
what i think is logical um but i'm not
going to think that the human
intelligence is the extent of the most
intelligent thing in the universe
um so similar to like free will on like
whether
we have it or not we're going to act the
same but if you think it's a simulation
cool i can't disprove it or prove it i'm
not gigabrained enough for that
no i get you well i mean that's pretty
gigabrain uh pretty gigabrain response i
give you that
my kind of take on the whole simulation
thing is
so i look at things very uh in a very
basic straightforward way
i just look at the facts and see if i
can what i can take yeah and
he says we're in a simulation right got
it okay i understand the three
the three things he says either either
we did it and we got that either
something happened
so catastrophic that um we never were
able to advance that far or we decided
it would be inhumane
but my issue which would really i'd love
to interview him one day my issue which
i can't get my head around
is but i definitely think that we're
gonna get that from a tech
standpoint but who says that somebody
got there before us like we we could
just be
like time could just be this linear and
we are the first
and then i don't know and then we
eventually get there it kind of that's
my only issue with it because i do
definitely agree that
you know things have advanced so far
yeah and so quickly
um but you mentioned free will so go on
i gotta get your thoughts on that do you
think we have free will
i think that we have free choi so i
think in free will there's two different
things that we should consider
that everyone is conditioned and you
could say that based on your nurture
you do not have absolute free will to do
everything outside of where you're
conditioned i don't think that
conditioning counts as an impediment to
free will i think if everyone is
conditioned then let's just consider
okay can you make your own actions
without being manipulated by like an
internal party
i do think that we do have free will
because i don't think that conditioning
is an
impediment on free will as much as a
feature of it because
we live in a world where there's factors
and things intermingling you
have free will amongst those things to
choose however i also think that
astrology
and being able to predict the future and
see cycles repeat
maybe even ta which i call astrology ta
for all of reality
cycles repeat and we can use that to
discern that there's a larger framework
so i believe that everything is
completely and wholly determined
i think that if you're saying that
there's some things that are determined
and some things that aren't
that you're just scared to say that it's
all determined because you think that
that means that you aren't making your
own decisions
i would argue that we're completely
making our own decisions and that if we
were omnisciently at the end of the
timeline we would be able to see
how we make all of those decisions so we
are both the agents of our own life
and we are playing a life that has been
predetermined because i think that the
most logical conception of this and this
is really wacko and weird and i've
written a lot of papers on this i've
gotten a lot of mixed opinions whether
it's like insane or kind of makes sense
is that
we're experiencing time linearly when it
must be a completely larger system
that is so many dimensions and we have
to simplify it down into
this follows this follows this i don't
believe in causality i believe in
like a chain of interactions and
everything is happening we're
experiencing it linearly so we both have
the free will to create
our own lives but if we were not humans
we were
gods being able to see the entire
timeline we would see
everything we're about to do even if
we're the ones doing it so like you are
writing your own story
and living out at the same time yeah
interesting interesting yeah no it's
good it's good um
i i often wonder i i also agree i think
that
we're we're living time linearly but i
don't think that that's how it actually
is
i don't think it seems yeah that if we
were gods or on a higher level or
whatever
we would be able to see i even have this
idea about reincarnation
whereby say you have like this bubble
right so time isn't linear
it's just this bubble i think that you
can exist
simultaneously in different in different
eras and times even while you're still
alive yeah
i genuinely think that's possible
because time isn't linear so like
if i let's say god forbid i died
tomorrow
i could easily be brought back three
weeks in advance let's say a bait
i'm the new baby that's born at the same
time as me being alive because time's
not linear
so i have this whole theory about
reincarnation which i definitely think
is true like i definitely think
there is we are you could meet yourself
because time isn't linear does that make
sense
there's some yeah there's some weird
ways that that could work
um when i was in a couple metaphysics
courses at nyu
i got really deep into time travel
because there's arguments about how
long yeah there's legitimate arguments
for why or why not it's logically
possible
and why or why not it's physically
possible like there are two different
arguments
the physical possibility can almost be
explained easier
than the logical one or i'm sorry the
logical one can almost be explained
easier
but the physical one can be an issue
because like if you're meeting yourself
then parents and descendancy and things
like that and like messing up the
timeline and how
harry potter where harry meets himself
is a good example of something that
is not logically consistent basically um
if someone's to go with that they can
look into it where harry meets his
himself
across with his patronus and like the
sixth film i think
um and yeah i think that um there's a
lot you can do with time travel where
it's not it's like a highly discussed
academic topic like it's not taboo
um and no i tend to think it will likely
be possible and that we could really
mess up
we can mess up a lot if it goes wrong so
it's very exciting i'm excited to
probably look down maybe in my next life
or a next planet and be like huh earth
earth everything up because they
time traveled back
and messed up a berth yeah
well time travel forward is possible
it's the time it's time travel backwards
because if you're
like i'm obsessed with with time travel
right interstellar is my favorite film
so if you're moving um faster
than the speed of light or like if
you're let's say you remove yourself
because obviously time is not fixed it
depends on like mass and gravity
so if you go to another planet with like
a larger mass then
time will obviously move slower for you
so then if you then come back to earth
everybody's aged but you're still the
same
so time travel forward we get but i have
no idea how time travel back
would work i don't know if you know yeah
go on some of the yeah some of the time
travel back that would
it would involve having to go back to a
specific event
and then some of there's some weird
theories um like you
would kill yourself how do you get back
but how do you get back that's the thing
is that the physical the physical part
is often theorized
where like it yeah where it's
not clear how you would physically do it
but it logically makes sense
that's why like the logical thing is
like if yeah where physically you know
you can make something up and there's a
lot of issues of like
double space where if you're time
traveling somewhere would you
run into an object there and then not
exist so there's like issues of like you
want to make sure that your time travel
box is like in a field
there's it's really cool it's really
cool there's some cool if anyone
wants those resources i can pull out my
old textbooks and like
tell you the articles and things but uh
yeah yeah
yeah no it's a great topic it's been so
brilliant chatting to you
um i feel like we have so much in common
um i'd love to come to dubai when you're
settled i feel like we
really could we could talk for hours
over a drink and just like
talk about absolute rubbish i'm sure we
could but
where can people find you what are you
up to just plug yourself now
i am marin altman on all socials so
that's mostly
tick tock twitter instagram and youtube
can't think of anything else i'm on so
if it
if it's me like scamming or asking for
money it's not me people fall for this
every video they're like thank you for
sharing this
telegram group where i'm like pay me and
i'm like that's not me um
so watch out for scammers but marin
altman pretty simple
all platforms and um i recently started
a second
youtube channel so you can find both of
those in my links to
separate astrology and then astron
crypto you can subscribe to both if you
still want to see everything in your
feed but i was getting some feedback of
like i don't really want this so i split
it up like three days ago
so that's out but um marin altman
everywhere you can find me uh
pretty simple and yeah feel free to
leave anything i get all
i like to see what people leave the good
the bad the ugly so chime in
i love it marin thank you so much it's
been so brilliant
and we definitely need to meet somewhere
in the world we'll do it
yes 100 would love to bring you on my
show and chat
because i think we're yeah very very
similar
yeah absolutely guys thank you so much
for watching i will see you all next
week bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]